now in terms of paper currency money how
should zaka be calculated as far as
paper currency is concerned it is
interchangeable with gold and silver we
should try and find out the value of
your paper currency and that keeps on
changing we can either evaluate what is
the amount of currency that will reach
the nisab level either with the nisab of
the gold that 85 gam of gold or the
nisab of the silver that is 595 G of
silver so we should try and find out
what would be the cost of 85 g of gold
in your country in your currency or 595
G of silver in your
country in your currency now the differ
opinion that what should we take as
nisab should we take the nisab of the
gold of the silver some of the F say
that take the lower limit so that a
person
gives zakat even though the nisab is low
some of the fuk say that take the nisab
Which is higher so that that gives
advantage to the poor person and he not
pay till it reaches the high level of
the nisab while other fuk say that since
silver was used as a way of trading in
the olden days so we should take the
nisab of the silver and try and find out
what is your currency as far as 595 G of
silver is concerned but this option is
left but if you really want on to be
more sure then you can take the lower
level of nisab and normally silver the
rate of silver nowadays 5 95 G of silver
is much less than 85 g of gold we should
see what is the current value suppose
you're calculating the zakat to be paid
at one particular date whether it be the
first of Raman whatever it is we have to
find out what is the value of 595 G of
silver or 85 g of gold at that time
now at present in India the value of one
gram of gold is approximately 900 rupees
that will be approximate 22 $23 for one
gram of gold this rate of silver and
gold will change in each country what is
the value in India will change what's in
Dubai may change in America may change
in UK and the currencies is also keep on
fluctuating in India today approximately
for one gram of gold is approximately
900 rupees that comes to $2 to $23 that
means 85 g of gold the nisab level would
be 76,500 rupees approximately in
dollars it would be somewhere close
$1,900 if you want to take the disab
level of silver then one kage of silver
approximately cost in India 18,000
rupees that's equal to $450 so 595 G of
silver would cost approximately 10,710
rupees
and in dollar it will be about $268
approximately the rate will change in
Dubai will change in UK will change in
USA so wherever you're living you can
take any Financial magazine or economic
magazine and try and find out the rate
and you can calculate yourself and if it
reaches that level then you should give
zakat if it's above that also so 2 and
half% on whatever savings you have
whatever Surplus you have you have to
give that many zakat that year and also
there are many zaka calculators
available on online free as well aren't
there so